I can't rest my daughter deserves better  we all deserve better change never comes  easy  this war isn't going to win itself  all his children  it's June's legacy which changed me  changed you  she does that strong claws it's not safe  anywhere  we should all just leave these women  deserve to be helped but I can't do this  alone  [Music]  must be the squad  she is out there planning who knows what  kind of atrocities to visit upon our  righteous nation  I never allowed myself to see her for  what she clearly is beyond redemption  what happens in the next few weeks will  determine the future of this country  we're just getting started  you  you